this is a great topic we've moved on
from linear functions into real
functions now out real functions
it's just up it's just a syllabuses way
of saying look there are all these other
kinds of things that we can graph that
are straight lines okay so that's that's
old that B and it's to distinguish from
either in the future you get onto
functions that don't involve real
numbers what we've got here is the
Cartesian place now just draw for me
quickly a really really small Cartesian
point this idea of real functions is
that you've got an X you've got away and
these are both real numbers right and we
can come up with relationships between
these real numbers that draw out
patterns for us and that's what we call
grams now this is the Cartesian plane
right the Cartesian plane which is named
after Rene Descartes Descartes who is
most famous for saying I think therefore
I am
it's French you can't you cannot it's so
hard because you guys have note about
the Cartesian plane for so long it is
impossible for me to overstate what a
revolution it was to have the Cartesian
plane right Tanna as a relationship
between X's and Y's two sets of real
numbers because the Cartesian plane
brought to you in one fell swoop and
that's why it's a big deal why it's got
a name whites I've got his name on it
brought together two parts of maths two
like gargantuan areas of maths that for
centuries had nothing to do with each
other and you guys just claimed it
because you've been working with this
you just kind of fit to give it right
and the two branches are geometry
geometry is one of the oldest branches
of maths
there is way way back like the ancient
Greeks Babylonians all those guys that
knew about geometry because they wanted
to build stuff so you build stuff or you
look at the stars of geometry tada
geometry which is about shapes and lines
and and figures of all that kind of
thing and algebra we're two completely
separate ideas completely separate and
you know there were there were guys and
they were called geometers right because
that's what they they had like a ruler
and compass in them and that's how they
worked in maths right and then there
were these people who work with like
straight printables and numbers and we
see it was a completely different thing
right but these two I guess I guess the
most modern player I could give it to
you was you know how in physics of it
for those of you who study physics know
that there's like Einstein's theory of
relativity and then there's quantum
mechanics and maybe just like we know
that they're both kind of true but we
just can't we can't put them together
and people will be trying right um
I mean they've got ideas of how it might
fit but no one's got it on this is here
right the Cartesian plane that was it
for these two ideas right in one fell
swoop could say look there's something
called a circle right we have a
geometric definition for that and then
to say hey you know what there's a
there's an algebraic definition for it
too right and this is kind of like
almost second nature to us now
oh yeah the unit circle of course the
unit circle this is like for all the
mathematicians who were when this was
first introduced right so please
understand that what you are doing when
we just will give this a basic
definition survive that's right it's
very difficult you are bringing together
something that eluded bad magicians and
empty less of human beings for centuries
okay
amazing so as I said your functions are
relations right what you see is the key
thing here is that there's a
relationship between X of Y okay sir
an equation is a relationship
and in this case x and y are two real
numbers which is why we call these are
your functions as I've seen before but
you may not have caught it because it's
right at the beginning this is not the
only way to have different kind of
numbers compare the most notable sort of
distinction between this you can join us
right is something which looks just like
the Cartesian plane but has nothing to
do with it when when those are you get
two extension two which would be most of
you do we will talk about real numbers
and imaginary numbers and their
relationship which is the complex plane
right which which kind of follows many
of the same rules as this is it's
2-dimensional it's most important feed
but the important thing is that these
sets of numbers and how they relate are
not real numbers right there well
they're different kinds of numbers and
we'll get to that in time right now you
guys know mathematicians are always
inventing up language and symbols to try
and make things shorter so rather than
saying equations a relationship they
make it all that much shorter by saying
you know this is equal to if we call
this a relation right so it's gone the
other way from modern language which is
like yeah I ship that okay
mathematicians went the other way and
they said look this relationship between
x and y despairing of these two kinds of
numbers we'll call that a relation right
so anytime you see X's and Y's together
in the equation you get a relation
between them right that's that's all it
is okay another way of saying this
another important phrase that you'll
hear is that this is setting up ordered
pairs right this is a really important
phrase it's not that important for you
like in terms if you would say it very
much but this idea that numbers a pan
are and they pair up in some kind of
order like X is 1 goes to this one and 2
goes to this one and 3 goes to this one
so on okay so anytime you get an
equation with X and y and you get a
relation now a function is a special
client in relation a function is a
relation where
when I said they're ordered pairs right
ordered pairs this is this idea that you
put in X values and you'll get out Y
values okay so my my board works a bit
disorder too but if you put in the next
value right something happens in here
right something gets applied to your X
values and you get out or Y value okay
but as you can see in my very first
example that I gave you right
I'm x squared plus y squared equals one
this is a very fundamental simple object
but the critical thing to notice about
it is that if you put in an X value like
say x equals zero that's a pretty simple
value right if I put in x equals zero
here what does y equal to the answer is
like I've got it here right x equals
zero is all the y axis and if I say X 0
what's Y the X rays it's two things it's
one and it's negative one okay so when
you have a relation you can put a value
of x in and you can get more than one
value of y out in this example you've
got true values of Y up in other
examples you could get three or four or
infinitely many okay that's what's
happening in a in a relation right
depending on what you've got here I'll
give you the example of it if at the
minute in a second but let me finish the
sentence that I started a function is a
relation where when you put in One X you
don't get some number of wires out who
knows how many depending on what kind of
thing is in a function you're only going
to put in one X and you can only get out
one way
okay so we just estate back here I would
recommend you have this diagram because
it's so helpful for you to understand
what's going on this thing up here this
is a relation you put it in X you'll get
out or Y or some wise maybe one or two
or three or many however many in a
function you only ever get out one now
we're very familiar with functions we've
actually been like most of the things
that we work with are actually function
so what have we just been looking at
like what topic did we just finish
linear functions okay
so they're called linear linear
functions because if you put in one
value of s into this you'll only ever
get out one Y right it's like okay how
about x equals one okay how many points
on this graph how many points on this
line match up to this X equal one of the
answer is there's only one is only ever
one okay
that's a linear function what other
kinds of graphs have we been thinking
about in recent times
okay parabolas fantastic so so he's a
parabola this is this is a parabola can
we get to that and say here's a parabola
right again if I pick some value of x in
fact if I pick any value of x like say
oh no - three okay how many Y values
correspond to that and the answer is
only one okay so linear functions
parabolic functions they're also going
to be you know just one day in one day
out